alright guys so we're gonna be talking
about some romantic games and this is
going to be the second installment on
the Romantic period that I'm going to be
doing and last week I tried to draw a
parallel between the Romantic period
proper which is considered to be the
nineteenth century and what I consider
to be the result of the Renaissance of
well a New Romantic period that is being
ushered in by these fantastic alpha0
games this week I was thinking about
showing you some more alpha0 games but
as I started doing a little bit of
research I found that a lot of really
good players that are really good at
explaining stuff had already done a
really good job at going through these
games I'm thinking particularly of this
series of videos that English
Grandmaster Matthew Sadler did and I
would highly recommend them to anyone
interested in reviewing these games so I
thought well it seems like it's already
been done it would be redundant to do it
myself
especially cuz I didn't think I could
really do it better than it had already
been done so then I started scratching
my head and thinking well what am I
going to talk about today and I said
well Romantic period I mean really do
these guys in the 19th century play more
romantic chess than we play today and I
wasn't entirely sure that the answer was
yes maybe if you compare the 19th
century games with like games from the
1950's or 1940s you could make a case
for it so I started doing a little
research and I started looking up some
recent games and my recent I mean last
10 20 years to see what was going on
and I found some unbelievable games of
this romantic style so what I thought I
could do is present a case to you today
that the Romantic period maybe wasn't
necessarily assured in by alpha0 that it
has actually been in place for quite a
few years now and immediately this one
game came to my mind and what I'm going
to do is instead of showing you entire
games I just want to throw positions at
you that happened in these recent games
and the unbelievable moves that were
played so it's going to be sort of like
a ping pong type of arrangement because
there's just so many that we wouldn't
have enough time to go through all of
them so I remember I was watching this
game like the day it was played and I
was like this this can't be happening so
black had just played the move Knight to
h5 this is not the romantic period but
what would you play yeah oh yeah my bad
yeah okay so you're playing with white
yeah what would you do
okay so II five looks interesting and
what are you gonna do after Knight takes
g3 right so it would be really nice to
get this Queen over here and give
checkmate but maybe I can play f5 I mean
I'm still not entirely convinced this is
right and after takes Queen here and
maybe I can take and after rook takes I
can go here it's very scary
I'll admit that much
oh yeah so here even better that's it's
very it's very playable so let's see
this idea of 'if I've just opening up
the diagonal for the bishop does seem
very logical maybe I shouldn't help you
make your attack stronger with Knight
takes g6 what happens if I just start
with that fire okay but now it's very
different right because your your queen
is not getting to h5 so easily and also
your knight is not coming in yeah
by the way that the two players I had
never heard of them before I was you
know there are like 2500 players and
playing the Chinese championship and I
remember the day the game was played
because Spiro said this is the game of
the decade so yeah so in the game this
f5 mood is really a very important
resource I mean it sort of reminds me of
this famous Fisher Benko game I don't
know if you remember where he played
this rook to f6 and then got the Bishop
on the open diagonal and it was over so
you have romantic and then you have just
rabid you know Bishop takes d6 right and
after Queen takes e5 and after Queen e7
night g3 and after Knight takes g3 there
you go rook takes f6 not allowing black
to play the move f5 because notice if
you go H takes g3 no black gets f5 it
again so this is really the key move
so now I mean I'm gonna take the night
and then I'm gonna put the Queen on h5
and it's gonna be over you just have no
way of assisting this King on g8 so
likely it's not over yet by the way
it still gets pretty amazing after this
so after a King g7 just queen g4 leaving
the night on g3 because it's more
important to give checkmate and after
rook g8 H takes g3 Knight b7 rook F 198
yeah I mean he's defending f7 Queenie 4
so we're threatening now Queen h7
followed by rook takes f7 so Queen b7
oh did I just say worked except no no
that's not it that's not really a threat
so d5 rook h8 and now what would you
guys play
close queen g6
oh yeah
so after takes rook takes this King is
really begging for mercy on h7 and now
you're just going to get checkmated rook
h4 and rook g6 checkmate so this game
was played in 2011 and I think Kasparov
was on to something when he said it was
the game of the decade have any of you
seen this game this is from I believe
last year
No 2017 you saw this game and actually
it might be easier to look at it this
way who's winning
well we're looking at this from the
black side so that should be a sort of
hint I mean black black just just played
the move e5 right sacrificing the e5
pawn but this is where things get really
crazy he goes D takes c3 yeah and after
rook takes d8 pawn takes b2 and now King
eat 2
rook takes the eight and queen takes B
suit b2 and I mean once you got rid of
that B to pawn it seems like the worst
is over right Knight a for Queen c2
Knight c3 and King f3 so this is the
position black had envisioned when he
sacrificed the Queen now the problem for
white is that this King is very
vulnerable here and should we ever get
to play move like well g4 perhaps
wouldn't work so well because it would
enable the f4 square for the King but if
we could get a Bishop to g4 then that
would definitely create some serious
mating threats so black plays rook d4
the idea is if you go Knight takes c6
well then Bishop g4 is checkmate and if
you go E takes d4 well then I just go
Knight takes and after King III Knight
takes c2 and up a piece
so black reasons I'll just go h3 and
this way I'm threatening to take on c6
because there's no Bishop g4 and also if
what if black gives me enough time I'll
just go Bishop h2 g4 and hide my King
away on g2 so h5 again
you can't play Knight takes c6 because
of Bishop g4 and after pawn takes pawn
takes is checkmate so white decides to
play Bishop h2 threatening to go either
g4 or King g3 so g4 King g3 and now
we're Ditu so if you take the 94 and
after king of 4 or king h4 then we just
take the Queen and we're still up a
piece right so maybe like king h4 take
with the Bishop just up a piece so white
plays Queen b3 94 check
only move King 2h for Bishop e7 check
only move King takes h5 and now what is
the mating sort of pattern or image that
we're looking for
what's that
yeah I mean what kind of image would
would you think about if you if you're
trying to deliver checkmate with black
what would it look like
any ideas the way the way this one the
one on D - okay I mean this rook on D -
seems fairly active well this one in a8
isn't really doing anything that's what
he did like kings yeah well no it's
gonna take - usually just play King G
south so after Bishop f4 you went Bishop
f5 and now you're threatening to play
rook h8 and rook takes h6 checkmate
so Bishop h6 King h7 Queen takes b7 and
what now
no just rook takes f2
very important move because now we're
actually threatening night take night g3
checkmate so we're not just pawn
grabbing right it's not like you say
well free pawn right he actually just
wants to go for checkmate and that pawn
was in the way so now White has to deal
with two fronts right g3 and also the H
file so Bishop g5 and now
we can move yeah
yeah so Knight takes f7 was played and
then Bishop g6 King takes g4 95 and
white resigned right because if king h4
well we can just go King here and after
oh wait we can't do that because we're
pinned ha so you would actually have to
go to g8 and then after Knight takes
then Bishop takes g5 right because this
Bishop is pinned so even if you go
Knight age six we can just go rook takes
and it's still checkmate so you know I
would argue that this could also be
considered the game of the decade I mean
the other one was pretty good but this
one is not bad either
let me show you a couple more games that
were played recently this one's actually
played was it this year or last year
white is david par of yan and black is a
goal above savvy le golden bomb both of
them grandmasters this was I would say
we were actually discussing before we
started this lecture you know what
really constitutes a great game is it
just a mind-blowing move that was played
or a mind-blowing sequence of moves is
the opposition that the opponent is
facing relevant of course it is but how
relevant is it it's not clear to me
right there's no there's no definition
of what a great game is you kind of know
when you see it but I think that the
opposition also the level of resistance
you know you a great game you feel like
you had to win it like three or four
times over like this game that we just
saw I think is a great game because
black had to create all these different
mating patterns in order to really crack
White's position I wouldn't necessarily
call this game that we have here like a
great game on the same scale as the
previous ones but I think it's also very
romantic in in essence so what would you
guys play with white alright very good
and after Bishop f5 all right so I mean
the point is that if you go King takes
h7 rook age three Bishop takes and you
pick up the Queen right so that's a nice
discovery the problem is that black can
throw in this in-between move and this
makes things a little bit more
complicated
so your queen here because maybe here
I'm able to play this movie so alright
right c3 but you can't because so after
Knight f6 check King g7 what was your
idea
so Bishop h6 very good and after King
takes so again right the idea if you
take the bishop here we have this
discovery and we pick up the Queen so
the King can't go to the h-file so King
takes f6
whoa and after Ponte I mean if King
takes
are you
yeah not so clear
so you want to stall for a minute okay
so if I go here you probably want to do
something like that well but if you go
g4 then then you allow my king to to
escape I'm not buying it
you want to go to d2 okay so you're
definitely threatening mate I can't
argue with that
it is so what if we do something like
Bishop b4
I mean I'm playing
I see I think that we have still alive
all right and can we do yeah this looks
definitely like I mean for all it for
only a piece we're only a piece down and
we're gonna get it back yeah so let's
see do I have anything better here cuz
Queen g5 really is a problem hmm
Bishop e6 doesn't solve anything now
this might be a good solution but white
decided to go for g4 threatening g5 mate
and if you take here then I still have
the discovery right and I win your queen
and of course well if you take the Queen
oh no not g5 yet sorry rook f3 check
and once you block the check then g5 is
checkmate it's kind of a nice smothered
mate so against g4 black plays this
crazy counter-attacking move Bishop f4
the point is g5 doesn't work anymore
because you just take it and if you play
Bishop takes off for then I can take
your queen because against g5 now I have
the g7 square available for the king
so after here
Bishop here
here I can always do this right so yeah
so once the Kings shakes loose from f6
it seems like the worst is over from
black but this is really the key moment
and we have to think that White had to
have seen this position when he played
Knight takes h7 and he had to have seen
the next move which is not an easy move
to see have any of you ever seen the
game Toure Adams Tori Tori was a Mexican
player Adams Tori very famous game
actually a very famous puzzle the game
is not so famous but there's a position
that's just crazy and I think that white
had definitely done that puzzle it at
some point because the the idea was was
there white played the move Queen c7 but
you didn't say it so again well it's a
good move after Bishop takes g5 is
checkmate
and you're also threatening Queen e7
checkmate so you took on h6 you're
saying bring the rook over this one okay
and what are you gonna do
well this rook is hanging right I was
looking at Queen d6 because again the
idea is I was to deliver checkmate with
g5 yeah but the problem is if I do this
I think you can just do something like
that well this book is so important
because it cuts your King off from the
e-file yep and after takes
you do get a time this time you check
again yep yeah that's a problem so
bringing the rook in doesn't really help
so black took on h6 and now after Queen
e5 King g5h for King takes rook h3 yeah
right because if King takes simply Queen
g3 is checkmate
so King g5 Queen e7 and he resigned
because well if you go King takes g4
Queen h4 is checkmate if you go king f4
Queen III followed by Queen g3 is
checkmate
and if you go f6 again Queen III takes
and Queen g3 is checkmate so this is
just kind of an average game for what
we've been seeing from the past few
years I mean it's not an average game
but it's a nice game I want to see if I
actually hadn't thought to show the game
Adams story but it's going to be useful
to compare the idea that we just saw now
I forget the exact year but I think this
is it
all right that's enough
yeah this is it
so move 18 okay
no no this is this is an other Adams it
isn't a very famous game this has seen
yeah very famous absolutely so after
Bishop takes f6 it's white to move what
would you guys play here all right
anybody else
Brook where work takes 8 and after rook
takes and after Queen takes yeah I mean
I don't think that we've really made a
lot of headway here what looks a little
bit strange about blacks position like
something that could become a problem
its Queen why the Queen it is undefended
and also it's I wouldn't say overloaded
at this point but the Queen is
undefended and it's doing a very
important thing right now which is
protecting the e8 rook which is very
important to protect because this King
doesn't have any escape square so we see
that the back rank turns out to be an
issue for black so White's next move has
to target the unprotected piece and
exploit the tactical theme here which is
the back rank very good
now this is this isn't an epic game
because of queen g4 right this is just I
just play queen g4 on every Tuesday
basically but after Queen b5 it seems
like black is able to keep the balance
right because the Queen moves while
still keeping the e8 row protected very
nice
Queen c4 so again if we take the Queen
we get mated in the back rank which is
not good
so black says okay you can have it drawn
right queen g4 Queen b5 but that
wouldn't make a game epic well if you
take the rook what happens if I just
take it what's that
so you want to take this rook here but
then the rook just takes it and you
don't really have enough pieces
threatening the back rank to really give
checkmate this is really the tough part
queen g4 in Queens d4 have really been
the warmups
oh you're on fire yeah yeah so now the
queen is completely overloaded it has to
go back to b5 if I don't know if
everybody sees it but you can't play
rook takes Queen because of back rank
checkmate
you can't play Queen takes Queen also
because a back rank checkmate so you
have to move your queen and you have to
stay along this diagonal so black played
Queen b5 and what now
a for first yeah well if you play Queen
takes b7 it seems like an interesting
move
because I can't play rook takes e to
because of Queen takes c8 and I can't
play Queen takes oh yes I can
because if Rick takes I have rook c1
yeah nice little counter-attack there so
Queen takes me so it would be pretty
epic blunder what's that
yeah oh yeah good try
yeah it would still be epic you'd still
make the record books so after a four
Queen takes a four
now
okay
so same idea right you still can't take
on e4 because of Queen take c8 so you
have to move your queen but the
difference now is that you don't have
Queen takes e to so this is a really
sophisticated part this a4 move followed
by rookie four to prevent the Queen
takes e to counter-attack
so now after Queen takes b7 black
resigned because the Queen is completely
overloaded and we don't have any squares
for the Queen all right and on the next
move we're going to lose the rook it's
not bad that was really loud so actually
I'm gonna save this one forgot to
include it building this little database
with the most epic games ever played and
I forgot about this one
alright so let's close out of that well
I'm going to show you a couple that
you've probably seen because they're so
famous close your eyes because I got to
do the thing there has anybody ever seen
this game
yet Apollo's was playing with white and
Shiro was playing with black actually
I'm gonna do this thing was it
controlled - yeah 1998 No
no to win always
so I'll give you I'll give you a hint if
the black King gets to e4 the endgame is
winning for black well I mean if you
give up all your pawns in the process
it's not you're really going to need to
hold on to these at least these two
pawns so it would be the first move the
most obvious moves okay so let's start
with King d6 what were you thinking
Ponte here this is actually how the game
went and Bishop h3 is considered the
most brilliant move of all times
oh yeah so good congratulations that's a
really hard move to find okay but it all
stems from understanding really some
fundamental unsweetened 'mentally church
of the position that moves sort of
suggests themselves and if you start
working through some variations
you'll start encountering some problems
and then moves that suggest that solve
those problems will also suggest
themselves so let's go through a couple
of variations like if we go King d6 like
the gentleman in the back was suggesting
white will play King f2 and after king
c5 King III and we're just not going to
get to the e4 square ever and we might
say well but c4 still looks pretty good
because then I'm gonna come here and I'm
gonna Queen this pawn but that's just
never gonna happen right Bishop takes f6
and if you ever come to b3
I will come to d2 and after a three I
will just spend the tempo with my bishop
and after a two there's just no way to
break through and if you ever try to go
King a2 in order to get your King to be
one I will just maintain my king close
by so we can't break through on the
Queen side
the other option is to try to actually
get the King to e4 so by moving the
bishop
maybe Bishop b1 but after king f2 King
f5 King III the White King makes it to
the center just in time
another option would be to play Bishop
b4 trying to tie you down to this G pond
and maybe push the F pawn but this
really doesn't accomplish much right
again we see this idea where black is
not making any headway on the Queen side
so once you understand that if the King
would get to e4 then you could play d4
and shut this Bishop down if it ever
takes on f6 from protecting the a1
square the game is over so the move
Bishop h3 is really the fastest route to
e4 so the game went G takes h3 right so
if you go King F - I'm gonna go King f5
and I'm threatening to go kini 4 and the
problem is if you go King III which was
the move you would want to play I can
just take on G 2 so the bishop is not
just out of the way of the King is also
threatening your G to pawn now you have
three and three is just too much you're
not gonna be able to stop me on three
fronts I know if it's anybody ever seen
jaws you know not like not with three
barrels you can't go down well except in
that movie did
yeah you know that line is completely
improvised it wasn't in the script yeah
so after Bishop h3 white took it so king
f5 King f2 and King before and now after
Bishop takes f6 you only have one pawn
for the bishop but White's position is
reasonable it goes now after d4 it's
it's not easy to stop this pawn white
played Bishop e7 and now King D 3 so
we're threatening to go King c2 and push
the D pawn Bishop c5 preventing King C -
but now King c4 and now Bishop e7 and
how would you play here king c3
so actually I have King b3 as the most
the point the point is really to get to
see - well I was thinking maybe against
King c3 I can actually play this movie
or maybe here I can actually go here and
tie you down to d4 because you can't go
see - because I take it and you can't go
a3 because I take this and if you push
d3 then I can just go here oh wait but
then you know you can go D - right right
in here takes takes are you how are you
gonna win I guess you should you can do
this right oh but wait I have this move
ha but announce it wrong nobody nobody
go back go back
but I have a question you can't go back
can't bring that sacrifice that Poland
got those we don't have enough for that
all right so where do you want to go you
want to go this way you might have
enough time yeah yeah I mean this looks
way too slow
yeah so you're you have a point here so
after King takes you could go King c4 I
suppose yeah that looks like a win
now can I do anything better though
can I go can I go this I guess not right
you're here and here and then you just
go yeah yeah
so maybe Kings c3 doesn't really make a
difference yeah and if I go here so we
was there yeah here you might you might
just go here right and then there
because my idea is that if you go to
this I go here and if you quit Queen I
take and then I take your queen yeah
yeah but king d3 looks good enough yeah
so maybe king c3 really doesn't change
things too much anyway it's a pretty
cool endgame Bensimon do we have time
for one more we have time for one more
alright alright let's make it a fairly
recent one let's actually just go to the
important position
I mean 2013 is pretty recent
I was actually watching this game live
it's a black to move Aronian Anand from
the tata steel tournament of 2013
Bishop takes h2 and after King takes you
want to go Knight g4 right remember King
g1 right hmm so let's say after Bishop
takes I guess right I guess I have to
take it do I can I go here because I'm
also threatening to take on h7 and I
might just trap your Bishop well maybe
not as long as you can play c5 maybe I
can trap it this way
but this ship takes h2 looks interesting
I mean the worst that could happen I
mean cuz I don't think it's a such a
good idea for a way to take on h7 right
if we go back if takes takes takes here
we're threatening to trap the bishop but
we're also threatening Queen h4 and
queen h2 checkmate so this doesn't look
that great for white maybe Bishop takes
h2 would have been good to an on play
the move c5 which sort of leaves
everything lingering in the air whether
it's Bishop takes h2 or whether it's
some b4 idea now so white took on h7 and
now black played Knight g4 so the idea
is to get the Queen involved and Aronian
played f4 shutting down the bishop it
would seem but here after C takes d4 he
takes d4 Bishop c5 kind of a
mind-boggling move and the point is that
after D takes e5 Knight takes e5 what do
you do
let's say well Knight takes f8 but then
I just take on d3 and then the Queen
comes in checks and King takes f8
material is even but I think you're
getting smoked here because you just
can't get your Queen side pieces out so
the other option I guess would be to go
Bishop to e2
[Music]
and are we gonna check here yeah check
takes and takes and now I'm threatening
checkmate on g2 and your Bishop is
pinned right so the Queen is hanging so
there's really no good way to stop Queen
takes g2 or Bishop takes you to so
Aronian played Bishop e2 and now Knight
d2 e file what's that
no there was nothing there so again the
idea is just to get the Queen right in
and now Queen g1 yeah by the way this
looks I don't know if anybody's seen the
Escher exhibit across the street but and
one of a sure's prints
he actually has a smothered mate sort of
hidden in the painting well it's
actually a wood carving huh what's that
across the street in the Hall of Fame
there's an exhibit on display by MC
Escher I highly recommend it so white
took the other night thinking well now
there's gonna be no night up to after
Bishop takes d4 King H one night takes
g4 took on f8 and now f5 again a very
strange-looking move because everything
is just hanging now I'm guessing the
point of f5 is that against Queen h4
which would be the move we would all
make White has this nice defensive idea
queen h7 getting the Queen's off the
board and white is up in exchange this
still looks very promising for black but
it's not necessarily checkmate so we
just ask ourselves what is our opponent
trying to do queen h7 so f5 simply stops
that
and it also stops ninety well ninety
four is not possible because of the pin
so I guess miss Queen 87 Knight g6 yeah
so this also prevents Queen h4 makes a
lot of sense but Queen f6
I will take your knight and then I will
resume my threats along the H file so h3
Queen takes Queen e2 Queen h5 all right
we can't take this night because this is
checkmate so Queen h5 and now after
Queen d3 yeah just a nice little
interference there so if you take on e3
you will get checkmate it in two moves
or here wherever you like this you can
choose so actually after Bishop b3 just
resigned because you just can't stop
Queen takes h3 so hopefully I've made a
case that when you hear this term the
Romantic period should necessarily take
you back to the 19th century I mean
there's there are plenty of romantic
games taking place right before our eyes
and I've just started to assemble this
database and I think it's gonna be
growing quite quickly and I'm thinking
of games are coming to my mind that
we're brilliant - there's a Kamsky
dangler end also I'm gonna once I get
home and start plugging some stuff in
here but anyway plenty to look forward
to so thanks for listening and I will
see you guys next week
you
[Music]
you